there are two pieces of good news
recently at the khan academy that i
think i need to tell you about and then
i have a request for you so the first
piece of big good news is that there's
this thing called the tech awards and
it's kind of like the Academy Awards of
nonprofits using technology to help the
world it's given by the San Jose tech
museum but it's an a worldwide event for
those of you don't know San Jose it
smack in the middle of Silicon Valley
and they give this award for four people
they think that are having a high impact
in the world and one of the awards is
the Microsoft Education Award Microsoft
is a corporate sponsor for that award
and the Khan Academy has one where it
hasn't won one yet it's one of the three
they calling they're calling us well
they're calling us all winners which is
very nice their color where we're
laureates in education so we all get the
same benefits of exposure and all of
that and I'll talk about that in a
second and that's where I'm going to
need your help but what they're going to
do is they've we're going to get some
exposure and this is a big event later
in two months from now that i'm gonna
tell you about but they're going to give
one of us fifty thousand dollars which
is nice because it you know you can't
retire off of it but we could use that
maybe to translate some of the Khan
Academy videos or pay for more tools or
computers or who knows whatever so it'll
be it'll be a nice impact and more it's
it's kind of the prestige effect of it
it'll be a good thing for people to know
about the Khan Academy but the thing I
need to get your help on is that because
khan academy is one there's this big
fancy gala in the the san jose
convention center 1400 people black tie
affair it's going to look something like
this you know i'm gonna be there and you
know this this could be me next year you
know maybe i'll wear well you know i'll
have a tuxedo on this it's a big fancy
event and all sorts of big people are
going to be there al gore is going to be
the keynote speaker at the event they're
giving him a humanitarian ward i think
for his is all of his is a environment
talk but the idea is is that this is a
big exposure event for all of the
nonprofits that are going to be there
and Khan Academy obviously is going to
be one of them they're going to make a
three-minute video for each of the
nonprofit's and this is kind of Khan
Academy's chance to to show the world
what it is and what
good for and hopefully how much impact
it's having and so my request to you is
take your webcams out take your webcams
out and take you know a little it could
be 30 seconds it could be a minute or
whatever and just say what Khan Academy
is doing for you how you find it helpful
is it you know has it helped your grades
is it changed how you view mathematics
or science or change that what you want
to major in I get written notes and
emails from you guys every day and I
actually read all of the comments and
all of the emails although I don't
necessarily have time to respond to all
of them but I read all of them and
they're frankly what keeps me going
because as you know right now Khan
Academy is is not generating this is the
computer screen is not generating much
much money just because it's it's free
and I want to keep it that way because I
think everyone should have access to an
education so I want y'all to say you
know what's it doing for you and and and
and how much this can change the world
and change the future of education etc
etc and you know don't say anything you
don't mean but yeah I'm going to take
that whole collage and I'm going to give
it to this video producer in Los Angeles
who's making the videos for this for
this fancy event with Al Gore and we'll
put them all together and I can't
guarantee that your video will be in it
but I want to make a collage because I
really want to give a sense from the
users of Khan Academy to this audience
that'll have not only Al Gore but all
sorts of fancy bigwigs from Silicon
Valley all the CEOs of all the tech
firms and all the venture capitalists
there who might be in a position to help
get Khan Academy funded I want to I want
to let them know that it's having real
impact with real people and really all
over the world so if you want to say it
and different language or indifferent in
a mix of languages go ahead and do so
and so the other big piece of news is
that i have quit my job quit my day job
quit day job day job which at least from
my point of view is a pretty big deal up
until yet this past Monday Khan Academy
was a part-time effort but it's starting
to gain a lot of steam and I've just at
that point where I realized that this is
I feel my calling and I think I get much
more impact on the world then when I go
and try to
turn the economic indicators and look at
Securities and figure out which way the
market or the economy is going to go and
spend an hour here I can make these
videos that will educate thousands or
millions of people all over the world as
long as the internet exists so I decided
to quit my day job I'm obviously living
off my savings but I've told my wife
I'll do this for a year we have you know
we have a little bit of a cushion so
I'll do this for a year if I can't get
it self sustaining by may be pitching to
the crowd over here or who knows how
else I can get it self sustaining then
I'll go back to my job but if I can't
get it self sustaining that I can make
videos the rest of my life and really
cover every topic ever known to man so
my request you make say what what Khan
Academy means to you and in video form
it can be very informal very fun very
silly will show it hopefully at this big
fancy black tie affair and hopefully
that'll get the newly or pseudo
unemployed Sal to a point where he can
do Khan Academy full-time